Speaker 1: All right. Let's go through a few
different news stories from the last 24 hours.
Today is the NRA convention, National Rifle
Association in Houston, Texas. It is also Texas,
the state the site of the deadliest mass shooting
in a school since Sandy Hook a decade ago.
And Donald Trump is going to be speaking at
the NRA convention. Greg Abbott is going to be
speaking there. Ted Cruz is going to be speaking
there. And all of them blame everything other
than guns for the mass shooting that took place
earlier this week. That's what Republicans do.
There has been increased pressure that
I mean, listen, there's been pressure
that the convention not even happen. It's
a vile event by an organization whose goal
is just to sell guns. Their clients are the gun
manufacturers. They are paid by gun manufacturers
to increase demand for guns. That's what they
do. But short of the event being canceled,
there's been pressure on people like Donald
Trump not to speak there, but Donald Trump
plans to speak there and he is doubling down,
posting to his you know, his I guess it's a social
media platform. Truth. Social truth.
Speaker 2: Central.
Speaker 1: Yeah. He posted, quote, America needs
real solutions and real leadership in this moment,
not politicians and partizanship. That's why I
will keep my longtime commitment to speak in Texas
at the NRA convention and deliver an important
address to America. In the meantime, we will
continue to pray for the victims, their families,
and for our entire nation. We are all in this
together. Going on to say a horrible time for our
country. The idea that because we need solutions,
it makes sense to speak at the NRA. The NRA
is never going to have a solution to school
shootings or shootings in general. The NRA wants
more people to buy guns. One of the ways that you
get people to buy more guns is to make them
believe that it's really dangerous out there
or to actually allow it to be really dangerous
out there. It's sort of the same thing. If people
think they need a gun, they're going to go and
buy a gun. And then if there's fewer shootings,
you go and you say, hey, that's thanks to
guns. Go out and buy more guns. Either way,
the NRA's solution is to buy more guns. And the
idea that they are going to be an arbiter or
a meeting point of any kind of actual
solutions is absurd. It is insane that,
what, 96 hours after this shooting in the same
state the NRA is gathering to talk about how
great guns are and how access to them shouldn't
be restricted. So Trump will be speaking there.
It's disgusting. It's depraved, it's absurd.
But it's exactly what we would expect him to do